je m'appelle cordon Claret donc je suis
gérante d'une entreprise de magasin de
prêt-à-porter
d'occasion qui se situe sur Saint-André
donc je me suis présentée aujourd'hui au
challenge du créateur de la catégorie de
prix de l'insertion actuellement je
présente donc des vêtements d'occasion
et tout ce qui est accessoires
type bijoux fantaisie
ceinture sac à main ma motivation en
fait tout était le fait que ma mère
réside en Angleterre et que j'ai pu voir
des magasins qui reprennent des
vêtements d'occasion pour les revendre
vraiment très petit prix ça rejoint un
peu l'état Emmaüs à bépiac etc etc mais
concrètement j'achète les vêtements
d'occasion avec les particuliers que je
revends en mettant en état et toujours
un tout petit alors moi mon poste à moi
donc c'est tout ce qui est la gestion de
de du magasin les parties
administratives
donc j'accueille le client j'accueille
les personnes qui veulent justement que
je reprenne les vêtements je dis la
responsabilité du lavage et du repassage
à une personne que je paye en chèque je
voulais montrer surtout aux jeunes
créateurs qui avaient autre chose à
créer sur la réunion que qu'il fallait
vraiment s'ouvrir un peu sur le monde
pour pouvoir apporter autre chose